deep learning is everywhere it's in
self-driving cars language learning apps
face recognition software chat bots and
social media apps
not only that but deep learning is also
used to make medical diagnosis through
medical image classification the uses of
deep learning are endless and that's why
now is the time to expand your knowledge
and be part of this field in udacity's
newly revamped deep learning nanodegree
program you will master fundamentals
that will enable you to go further in
the field launch or advance a career and
join the next generation of deep
learning talent that will help define a
beneficial new ai-powered future for our
world
you will study cutting-edge topics such
as neural networks convolutional neural
networks recurrent neural networks
generative adversarial networks and
build projects in pytorch
our hands-on project will help you
prepare your career in the deep learning
field
our experiential projects are open-ended
designed to reflect actual workplace
challenges
for anyone interested in this
transformational technology this program
is an ideal point of entry
now is the time to advance your career
in deep learning
enroll today in the deep learning
nanodegree program
[Music]